股神巴菲特說過
複利是世界上
第八大奇跡
但90%的人
卻只搞懂了一半
就算你今天去問
那些教複利的人
複利怎麼運作？
他們給你的答案
也會停留在
效率最慢的層級
買一檔股票
長期抱著
把領到的股利
再拿去買股票
但這些
真的是複利的全部嗎？
我先給你一個數字
你自己感受一下
假設你現在
手上有2萬塊
用這樣的複利方式
每年大概是賺5%
接下來
你每年都把
領到的股利
全部再投入
你猜
要花幾年
這2萬塊才能變成2億？
190年
對！你沒有聽錯
這已經不是
你這輩子能達成的事了
這是你
曾曾曾孫那一輩
才有機會看到的數字
如果複利
只有這一種玩法
那大多數人的
財富自由
根本就是個假議題
但問題是
真的有人
靠股票賺到第一桶金
甚至翻身致富
這些人是怎麼做到的？
答案是
他們用的
是更高層級的複利方法
我是小王子
在股市打滾20年
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續5年獲利破千萬
我先講一個
沒有人願意承認的事實
幾乎所有真正靠股市
賺到大把鈔票的人
用的都不是剛剛那種
最低層級的複利方法
只靠股利再投入
就能翻身的人
少之又少
就算真的有
也只有一種人
極致省吃儉用
活到很老的長輩
他們靠的
根本不是複利的威力
而是時間夠長
開銷夠省
那其他人是怎麼做到的？
這就要先搞懂
「複利」這個東西
先撇開不同的層級
多數人連
最基本的名詞意義
都搞混了
我們先來講
什麼是股利？
股利就是
公司賺到錢之後
分一部分的利潤
給股東的錢
這是公司營運的結果
跟你做了什麼操作
都沒關係
什麼是殖利率？
殖利率就是
把你領到的股利
除以你買進的股價
算出來的一個百分比
可以用來衡量
這筆投資相對於股價
回饋的速度有多快
很多人以為
殖利率越高
就代表這檔股票越好
但其實殖利率
只能告訴你
配息跟股價的比例
不能告訴你總報酬
這是第一個
常常被搞混的地方
那複利到底是什麼？
複利的核心是
把上一輪賺到的錢
變成下一輪的本金
股利再投入只是
複利眾多玩法中
速度最慢的一種
因為他一年可能
只滾動一次
這就是我說的
第一個層級
那第二個層級
跟第三個層級
又是怎麼運作的？
先講第二個層級
靠波段操作來複利
波段操作
簡單來說就是
不抱一輩子
買進股票
只抓一段
股票上漲的趨勢
有可能抱幾天到數個月
等趨勢走完
獲利到位了
就出場
落袋為安
為什麼波段
就能讓複利速度變快？
關鍵在於
單次的報酬率被放大了
股利複利
一年領一次的股利
殖利率通常
落在3%到5%左右
這個速度非常慢
但波段操作
賺的是一整段趨勢財
如果抓對方向
一次操作的報酬率
可能是 20% 30%
甚至更高
同樣是滾一次
波段滾出來的雪球
會比股利大上好幾倍
那實際上要怎麼操作？
波段交易看的
不是公司
每年配多少股利
而是看
股價的趨勢
和籌碼的動向
籌碼
指的是一間公司
股票的份額
一間公司
在股市流通的股票
是固定的數量
當你擁有某家公司
越多的股票
你就有越大的籌碼
你對這家公司的股價
就越有影響力
所以籌碼的動向
就是看
股票在誰手上
是在政府手上
還是在
某些金融機構手上
那股價趨勢怎麼看？
首先要看
這間公司
有沒有什麼新聞
當新聞發佈後
股價有什麼反應？
你能不能從股價裡
看出股票背後的故事？
波段交易者會在
趨勢剛啓動
籌碼開始集中的時候進場
然後抱著
等股價出現轉弱的跡象
再賣掉
收穫一整波
舉個例子
假設一檔股票
某一季的營收
超乎大家的預期
國外的投資公司
開始瘋狂一直買
然後股價兩個月
從50塊漲到65塊
如果你用
波段操作的方式
抓到這一段
你的本金
兩個月就成長了30%
下個月
你再拿這一筆
更大的本金
重複一樣的操作
這樣的速度跟
股息的複利
完全是天差地遠
這就是第二層級的複利
接下來我們來介紹
最暴力的第三層級複利
系統化當沖
當沖就是
當天買進
當天就賣出
股票不留隔夜
賺的是
當天股價
上下波動的價差
為什麼當沖能讓
複利的速度
再往上一個量級？
關鍵已經不再是
單次報酬率了
而是滾動的次數
波段交易
你每年頂多交易
幾次到十幾次
但當沖不一樣
你一天可以買賣好幾趟
一年下來
交易次數可能是
波段的幾十倍
甚至幾千倍
雖然當沖
單次賺的幅度不大
可能只有1%到3%
但是因為滾動的次數
多到極致
複利的效果會呈現
爆發性的成長
假設你一天
只做一次當沖
每次只賺1%
一個月就有22%
一年就有1000%
也就是說
你每過一年
本金就會多一位數
第一年2萬
第二年20萬
第三年200萬
更何況
你一天做很多次
賺的可能不只1%
這跟波段和股利
是完全不同量級的遊戲
但這裡要
特別強調一個前提
當沖要能真正
發揮複利威力
最重要的一件事
是要把交易方法
系統化
也就是建立一套
固定的選股邏輯
和進出場條件
讓每一筆交易
都照著同一套流程走
這樣你才能算出
這套系統
長期下來的
勝率跟報酬率
如果你當沖沒有系統化
今天用A方法
明天用B方法
就沒辦法有
固定的報酬
來達到這個
第三層級的複利效果
另外
他還有一個
其他層級
都沒有辦法
複製的優勢
當沖不需要本金
就算你手上
只有2萬的本金
你也能操作
100萬的股票
你只需要付出
買賣的成本
和虧損的金額
這有多恐怖？
我算給你聽
如果你的本金
就只有2萬塊
你去當沖一張
100萬的股票
賺了1%
也就是賺了一萬塊
實際上
你這次操作
就已經賺到
本金的50%了
相反的
當你虧了1%
你也會虧掉1萬元
你的戶頭
瞬間就只剩下
一半的金額了
這也是系統化的重要性
你不只是要
固定流程
就連「你可以玩多少錢」
「最多虧多少錢」
都應該要制定好
清楚的規則
只有在安全的系統中
你才能讓當沖
發揮複利的效果
但這也是為什麼
本金小的時候
真正的高手
會選擇用當沖
把複利速度
做到極致
那既然當沖的
複利速度這麼快
我們如果一輩子
都用當沖
不就世界首富了嗎？
我不排除
你可能是下一個世界首富
但一輩子只用當沖
不會讓你成為世界首富
因為這裡面
牽涉到一個關鍵問題
容量
你可能對於什麼是「容量」
還沒有什麼概念
我舉一個例子
你就懂了
當你的本金有1億
想當沖2億的金額
200元的股票
你就要買賣1000張
今天
你看到某檔股票
有30張等著以202塊賣出
你看漲
預期會漲到210
以前你只要買10張
可以直接買進
都用202塊買下
現在呢
你要買的張數
實在太多了
但是
想以低於210元
賣出的股票數量
連500張都不到
你如果買1000張
一定會有
超過一半的數量
都買貴了
換句話說
你想買的量
多到把股價推升了
這就是國中教的
供需理論
想買的很多
想賣的很少
價格就變貴了
你想賺錢
最多就只能買500張
而且這500張
沒辦法全部都在
最好的價格買下
買的價格差
買進的張數還少
自然而然
獲利就會大打折扣
除非你選擇去當沖
很多人參與的股票
如果每天都有
幾百億的金額
在裡面做買賣
就算你買進2億
股價也不動如山
但是
這檔股票
機會會比你
原本選擇的更好嗎？
畢竟
你買進2億
股價都不會漲了
別人要買進多少億
股價才會漲到
你想賺的金額？
最後你會發現
原來
當沖能賺到的錢
是有天花板的
跟你敢不敢無關
跟危不危險也無關
純粹是因為
當沖這場遊戲
能容納的數量有限
這就是我說的
容量問題
到了這個時候
你只好選擇
股價漲幅
50% 100% 的
波段操作
就算你因為
暴力買進1000張
少賺10%
你還是有
40%以上的獲利
假如你的本金更大
想買的金額
已經是幾百億的級別
那就要再退一步
改成長期投資
去賺穩定的股利
以及幾十年後
股票翻好幾倍的機會
這就是
資金上兆的巴菲特
只做長期投資
背後的真相
簡單來說
做的越短
複利越快
能容納的金額
也相對少
想玩的資金越大
就必須等的越久
賺的也越慢
所以結論很清楚
本金小的時候
用短線
把複利速度推到極致
等本金養大
你發現
短線已經容納不下的時候
就必須轉向波段交易
甚至長期投資
雖然犧牲掉
複利的速度
但是至少
賺到的錢
遠遠超過物價的上漲
複利的速度變慢
是你本金一路成長
必須經歷
最甜蜜的負荷
實際操作上
到底要怎麼進行？
這三個層級
你要怎麼切換？
本金來到多少錢
該做哪一種層級？
我給你一個
具體的階段策略
原則很簡單
能做多少是多少
假設一開始
你的本金不到200萬
你可以放心的
全部做當沖
雖然說
當沖不用本金
但是如果虧損了
還是必須拿錢出來賠
我所說的
系統化的當沖
並不是
每次都會賺錢
每次都賺這麼多
而是長期來看
經過半年一年
賺了幾百次
賠了幾百次
發現這套流程
平均每次
可以賺到這麼多
所以說
就算是系統化當沖
也一定會遇到虧損
你的本金
必須足夠支付
你遇到的虧損
但你不知道
你到底會遇到
多少的虧損
所以一開始
我建議你
小金額的來嘗試
每一次當沖
操作的金額
固定在一個區間
假設是5萬塊左右
也就是10元的股票
當沖5張
50元的股票
只當沖一張
統計一年
把損益累積起來
得到一張曲線圖
如果曲線
是向下的
代表這套當沖流程
會害你賠錢
就不要再用了
如果曲線
是向上的
代表這套可以用
但要特別注意
整張圖表裡
凹陷最多的地方
凹陷了多少錢？
假設凹陷了一萬塊
代表
你做5萬的金額
最多會虧損20%
而你的本金
至少要能承擔
這20%的虧損
也就是說
如果你本金200萬
最多最多
只能當沖1000萬的金額
因為你做1000萬
虧損20%
就是200萬
剛好把你的本金賠光
當你的本金
累積到300萬
你就可以操作
1500萬的金額
以此類推
逐步增加
那本金達到多少錢
你要改做波段交易？
取決於你
當沖的方法
不同的當沖方法
能容納的金額
就不一樣
當你明顯感受到
賺的沒有以前多
你當沖方法被影響到了
就是時候
來到第二階段了
重點趕快筆記
你不需要把所有的本金
全部拿去做波段
當沖能做多少
就做多少
假如你身上
有1000萬本金
你的當沖方法
做到滿
也只需要600萬的本金
你就拿剩下的400萬本金
去做波段交易
這才是有效率的
資金分配方法
但你要記得
當沖跟波段
是完全不同的遊戲
做當沖
你連這檔股票
公司是做什麼的
都不需要知道
但做波段
你要瞭解的比較多
最近有什麼財經新聞？
對哪些股票會有影響？
股票的籌碼
掌握在誰手上？
目前的股價
還有沒有上漲空間？
這些都是
你能不能賺到
第二層級複利的關鍵
那什麼時候要轉換到
第三層級的複利？
這裡
我得先講清楚一件事
就像前面所說的
一檔股票
籌碼都是固定的量
當你想買的數量
多到一定的程度
你就可以左右
股價的走勢
這時候
我們就可以稱你為
這檔股票的主力
這時你需要學的
是另外一個技術
如何在
不影響股價的情況
買進夠多的股票？
如何誘使那些
跟進買進的人
把股票低價賣給你？
如何讓更多人
用更貴的價格
買進你的股票？
所以什麼時候
要用第一層級的複利？
取決於你
是否學會這些技術
他們可以讓
波段交易的容量
達到另一個級別
但事實上
不學也可以
等你走到這一步
你的本金
已經足夠讓你
實現你理想的生活
真正讓你
提早使用
長期投資的原因
不是因為
你想投資的
量級太大
也不是因為
你學不會那些
主力該學會的技術
反而是因為
你手上錢多了
你害怕失去它
決定分配一部分
去做相對安全的投資
以免你
一路走來的心血
哪一天全部消失不見
畢竟你已經不需要
賺的很快了
你需要的是
賺的很安全
犧牲一些高層級的複利
反而
能夠讓你更踏實
更沒有負擔
我們把三個階段
串起來看
從2萬塊到幾百億
絕對不可能
一招就打遍天下
你需要隨著
本金的規模
換不同的工具
去匹配當下
最適合的滾動速度
這才是
一個普通人
真正能讓本金
快速成長
在此生達到財富自由
最可能的路徑
用講的都很容易
做起來
處處都是困難
最可能阻礙你
達到財富自由的原因
有兩個
第一
缺乏風險意識
90%投資人
要嘛太衝
都不好好控制
虧損的金額
要嘛太縮
因為害怕虧損
該做的不敢做
但真正的風險意識
是你控制好虧損
該做就做
該賺就賺
該賠就賠
用系統化的操作
指導資金安全的成長
第二
試錯成本不足
要找到一套
適合你
又真正有效的系統
需要花大把的時間
大把的鈔票
來重複測試和統計
我們這樣沒什麼時間
本金還少少的普通人
到底應該用什麼方式
來建立自己的投資系統？
我的建議是
直接抄別人的系統吧
有很高的機率
你能夠參考他的系統
建立你自己的系統
不要像我一樣
傻傻的摸索十幾年
才建立起
二三層級的複利系統
開始滾動本金
我不介意你
直接抄過去用
不要浪費你寶貴的時光
我都已經把它們整理成
7大當沖獲利術
和波段買賣的
價位設計法
全部放在我的
線上講座裡
裡面除了系統之外
我還會分享兩種
找到飆股的方法
趕快到資訊欄
點擊連結就能免費報名
講座的名額有限
如果點連結進去
沒有看到直播場次
代表額滿了
看完這部影片
你對賺錢的認知
應該已經提升到
新的維度了
但「認知」
在還沒開始行動前
都只在腦子裡
只有透過實踐
才能真正走向
你認知中的財富自由
我是小王子
我們下次見